chart stands for be secure hash
algorithm which is interesting given
that they just kind of been broken but
I'm not going to talk specifically about
the attack on sure today that's for a
different video but what I wanted to do
was talk it in a little bit more detail
about hash functions and what they are
and how sharp particular works so you
can get an idea of a kind of way these
things are implemented let's have a
quick look at what a hash function is
briefly because Tom's got somebody
covered it in this video and you've gone
into a lot of the reasons you might use
a hash function but kind of hash
functions I'm talking about are not the
ones that we've been talking about for
hashing passwords those ones have to be
quite slow in some sense because you
need them to be secure we're going to
talk mostly about the hash functions
that are used routinely in cryptography
for things like message authentication
digital signatures and so on so they
need to be fairly quick both to verify
and compute a hash function take some
string right let's say a b c and it
turns it into some fixed length string
that's not usually three long of random
so we know a bit string right but so so
u naught 1 1 or not 1 or 1 1 go forward
this way for however many bits that hash
function is now there's a few important
properties of hash functions that we
care about photography but the most
important one perhaps is that it's
essentially pseudo-random so that means
that we put in a b c and we get out
something that is in no way like a b c
and appears completely random to us and
if we change this even slightly because
it's appearing random this has
completely changed so let's have a quick
look at char 1 as an example just so we
can see this in action I'm on some page
that has a script that calculates hashes
on-the-fly
so I can put in ABC and you can see that
the hash is a 9 9 9 3 e and so on all
the way up to D right this is the sha-1
hash a sha-1 hash is 160 bits long if I
change this C to a D the hash has
completely changed so there's the
appearance of randomness the idea that
this hash is actually not related to
this at all even though it is and we
know it is because if I put C back again
we're back to a 9 9 9 3 so we can use
this divert
my message haven't been changed or
verified signatures on certificates and
we can do it knowing that we have the
appearance of an illness but actually
not random at all today we're going to
talk a bit about how you actually write
a hash function to do this how do we
take something that essentially isn't
random with a very known structure and
turn it into something that looks like
nonsense such that we can use it now
there'll be people raising a few
eyebrows I'm using sha-1 as an example
to do this but actually there's fairly
reasonable reason to do so first of all
you know we might also talk about the
weaknesses at some point but also char
warren bears a striking similarity in
structure to md4 and md5 which is seen a
lot of youth historically and shaft 256
and sha-512 which is char two which
currently is in some sense a standard
that everyone uses right
char free is quite different and that's
is something else one of a day so char 1
was developed by the NSA and released
and published in 1995 now a lot of
people don't trust things that the NSA
do sort of by default which might be
fair but in this case actually char warm
was quite good for a long long time when
there were some concerns read some more
recently much suit more serious concern
but originally the NSA weren't doing it
as a backdoor and stuff the NSA need
cryptography just like everyone else and
this is a good function md5 had a lot of
problems and so what they basically did
was extend it and make it better
shell one takes any length of string and
outputs a 160 bit value all right so
that's 160 zeros and ones the question
then becomes I've got a string but could
be ABC or it could be an incredibly long
file or you know a whole movie right and
I want to calculate 160 bit signature of
that how do I even get started doing
that well the answer is but I basically
have a loop that takes 512 bit blocks of
data one at a time until the files
expended let's look at an example of how
char long works on just a single message
of exactly the right length and then
we'll just talk briefly about what you
do when inevitably isn't the right
length which is almost always right so
char one takes a message of in blocks of
512 bits in length and if it's only one
block if the message is exactly 512 bits
in length then we only run it once in
and then we output the hash at the end
so sha-1 starts with an internal state
then we bring in bits of our message one
at a time and we change that internal
state and after we've done that at the
very end when there's no more message
left we just read what the internal
state is and that's our hash all right
so we're going to basically be taking
the internal state and updating it with
the message until we run out of message
and then as soon as that process stops
we can read the result that's how the
char firing of hash functions works so
our internal state we can wait so I'm
going to say H naught H 1 H 2 H 3 and H
4 now the internal state of char 1 it's
exactly the same length as the hash that
it produces which is 160 bits which is 5
32-bit words 4 bytes each you know for
32-bit machine this would be an int so
this is initialized based on some
constants which is defined in the
standard right we might talk about that
in a bit but it's not very important and
what we're going to do is we're update
these H's as we bring in our message and
then at the end we'll see what the HS
are and that's our hash function so how
do we do this well we have something
called a compression function it's going
to take in this data and a bit of
message turn it into another set of H
values and that's going to repeat as we
have message but that's only going to
happen once this time because my message
is exactly 512 which is very handy so
this is our compression function and I'm
going to rename these slightly just to
confuse everyone - ABC dearly so at the
beginning of our compression function we
copy B's it's the internal state into a
B C D and E we then perform 80 rounds of
shark impression function right which is
like this so times 80 now what that's
going to do is take in words from our
512 bit block of our message so if this
is our message here that message is 512
bits this is going to come in at this
point and be mixed in with this a b c
and d so well for now we won't talk
about exactly what's going on in this
compression function but the idea is
that the bits of ABCDE are being
combined together they're being shuffled
they're being computed around to make it
look more and more random as we go and
at the same time we're bringing in bits
from this message
to further increase the appearance of
randomness but also to make sure that
this char function is calculating a
digest on this specific message rather
than just a general one that's the same
every time for this message we're always
going to perform the exact same
algorithm so if we put in this message a
second time the char function will
produce exactly the same result now once
we've done this and we've shuffled up
ABCDE
we'll be left with a new ABCDE so a B C
D and E and then we finish this block by
bringing our H values down here and
adding them to these values here to
create a new H naught h1 h2 h3 h4 the
state is now been updated by whatever we
did in this compression function by just
adding to it all right now all addition
in char is done without any overflow
modulo 2 to the 32 what that means is
that if you ever go over the maximum
value allowed by a 4 byte integer you
wrap back around again right which is
one of the reasons why char carving
reverse because you might lose
information that way this is not
encryption we don't need to be able to
reverse it so this state is finished now
if our message is exactly 512 bits we
need these H naught H 1 H 2 H 3 H 4
values out that is our hash so for short
messages we're done I could just you
know go home in actual fact the the
principle of extending this to arbitrary
length messages write in increments of
512 bits is we copied this state back up
to the top and we repeat the process and
then we copy back up and we repeat the
process for as many blocks as we have of
our message 512 bits at a time of our
message we feed it in we alter the state
using this approach here and then we
read off a state when we're done right
that's basically how it works so be the
security of char is all winning this
compression function and what it's doing
is it sure yes after that if it's not a
multiple of 512 bits we're going to have
to do some padding right char only works
with 512 bit blocks so what we do is if
we have our message which is let's say
1z
Oh 0 1 1 0 1 it's not a very long
message if we want to pad that up to 512
bits we start with a 1 we pad we in 1 1
right so I'm going to sort of mark the
market the padding here so we know we go
with 0 0 0 0 and then we finish off the
message with the length of the actual
message in it so we know where to sort
of remove the padding which in this case
is 7 so in binary 1 1 1 so 1 1 1
obviously would a lot more bits for your
length then I have done my yet the idea
now this padding scheme ensures that
messages of the same length and messages
that end in the same way or in very
similar ways don't share the same
padding and don't end up being the same
that's very important so this approach
to Sharpe it's repetitive updating of
the internal state with a compression
function in essence is called a
merkle-damgard construction this was
sort of independently proved by Merkel
and damn God but essentially what's good
about it is if your compression function
is good and has good pseudo-random
properties then so does your shell
function which is of course very useful
right the problem is that the
compression function of sha-1 is not so
good that the attacks are too z18 they
can be reduced somewhat to about two to
the 60 something like this which it
becomes into the realm of possibility
for people with a lot of money